I've had hundreds of auditions it didn't
go well but I think I can't remember
them now because I think you block block
them out there so humiliating but I do
remember one for an advert for all the
chicken thing I feel like chicken
tonight that and you had to sing a
reggae song to a frozen chicken and I
can't sing
and the only reggae song I know is and
this is right in my kitchen what am I
going to do I'm going to kill that rat
so I write that stay on line and up as
well as that to just keep repeating that
to a panel of six people who just sat in
silent must adverts Oh auditions for
advert so humiliating and I think the
best advice is to forget about it the
minute you leave the room don't dwell on
it because for years I used to think oh
I'll forget it I hope you know I really
need this job on it for weeks I'll worry
about it but then after a while I'll
just I'll and the minute you leave the
room you forget about it some you'll get
most you want but and don't take it that
seriously that's my advice
you